let's go to george from littleton george
welcome to the show
hey david thanks a lot
thank you
i just had a quick uh kind of thing i've
been thinking about is
how do you combat the just the trumpian
way of
you know kind of talking like um like i
can tell you david
aliens
exist and
you question that i just say well
everyone's talking about it
you know just kind of that
kind of way of
speaking well haven't you heard
everyone's talking about it and you're
like whoa
isn't the news reporting on this
and it's just
kind of that same
you know oh well you can't trust the
news
uh george i'm not sure are you saying
what are good responses when people say
yeah yeah i don't know everybody says
the election was stolen like how do you
respond when someone goes everybody's
been saying that like if
you tell you that well it means
you know something just absurd like
aliens exist and i just keep
repeating that same type of argument
okay you want to do like a role play
we'll try it you'll be the person with
the belief and i'll kind of do it the
way i would handle it
exactly okay so like tell tell me like
everybody says we know the election was
stolen from trump let's start there okay
so give me that line and we'll go
through it
yeah so well the election was stolen
because you know everyone
everyone knows it
how do you know it
george how do you know why do you
believe the election was stolen
oh well you know because everyone's
talking about it um
it's been proven there's there's you
know all the facts are out there okay
who tell me for example who's talking
about it
oh oh fox news yeah fox news is
reporting on it and what did fox news
say
there's just a lot of the you know the
the election the uh the integrity of it
the the corruption
and in which in which state
did this happen where trump actually won
but the state was given to biden what's
one state that's an example of that
i think georgia was the biggest the
biggest one okay and and how do you know
that trump really won in georgia
yeah there was just so much election
fraud you can't trust it do you live in
georgia
oh so how do you know that that's what
happened in georgia
oh that that's what all the news is
reporting on it okay and how did they
say that it was stolen was it people
uh filling in multiple ballots did
someone hack something how did they do
it
were filling in ballots they were
bringing in the truckloads of ballots
and and uh
there was al all kinds of fraud it just
couldn't be trusted
and how do you know whether those
reports are accurate
there's just enough enough people
questioning it that that it's it's hard
to believe the results when a lot of
people question things do you tend to
assume that they're correct
i mean it's not necessarily they're
correct but that it just raises enough
questions for me to
not believe it a lot of people say that
the vaccine magnetizes you do you
believe that
now myself personally
okay a lot of people say the earth is
flat do you believe that
no so a lot of people often say lots of
things and you don't believe them why do
you think that this time the people are
right but in all those other cases
they're wrong
yeah i think you know just
can choose i guess what what
what i believe anyway i mean it's
actually harder with someone who i know
doesn't believe this stuff but you get
the point eventually we would get to
hopefully just getting them to to
realize
that um that that their opinion is not
really based on anything is that i mean
that's the idea i'm trying to give you
yeah yeah that that
definitely definitely helps when you
when you break it down that way yeah
just start asking for more of the
i mean ultimately it's a better thing
than just beating them over the head and
screaming at them so that's that's my
effort
definitely
all right george thank you for the call
i appreciate it thanks david all right
take care there's george from littleton
trying to do the tough work that's for
sure that is absolutely for sure